For the past four decades, Nicolas Cage has
been one of the most prolific and entertaining
actors in show business.
And this weekend, he’ll bring his singular
style to the exciting action-comedy "The Unbearable
Weight of Massive Talent," which features
the actor as, well, Nick Cage, an accomplished
blockbuster action star who's ready to retire.
However, once he's hired to attend the birthday
party of a wealthy superfan named Javi, he
gets something of a second wind … and is
then recruited by a CIA operative Vivian to
channel some of his most iconic fictional
characters for a dangerous government mission.
The film marks the culmination of so many
memorable moments from Cage's prodigious screen
career, from his sprawling adventure stories
to searing action-dramas.
"Is this supposed to be me?
It's grotesque.
I'll give you $20,000 for it."
So to celebrate this marvelously meta role,
here's a look back at Nicolas Cage's best
action movies of all time, ranked.
Just before the MCU emerged as a mainstay
of the movie industry, Cage became one of
Marvel’s most fiery superheroes of all time
– the title character of 2007's "Ghost Rider."
Cage stars as Johnny Blaze, a reckless stuntman
who’s forced to become the enforcer of the
demon Mephistopheles.
"You."
"Hello, Johnny."
"Stay away from me."
Johnny has no choice but to do the devil's
bidding because, as a teenager, he sold his
soul to save his father.
With Johnny Blaze, Cage's performance manages
to make the character both ruthless and redeemable,
haughty and heartfelt, and condemned but not
contemptible.
It's a bold balancing act that's perfectly
matched by the visually arresting action scenes.
"Let's ride."
There’s something so satisfying about seeing
Cage bring his skills to the screen for films
that have a bit of a supernatural bent, and
"Drive Angry" is another prime example of that.
Cage stars in this 2011 3-D film as John Milton,
a man who escapes from Hell armed with nothing
less than Satan's own gun.
Milton is on a mission to get revenge against
a cult leader named Jonah King, a devil worshiper
who’s murdered Milton's daughter and stolen
his baby granddaughter in order to sacrifice
the child and bring about Hell on earth.
It's clear throughout the flick that Cage
has a lot of fun portraying this unholy, semi-human
character who has absolutely nothing left
to lose — not even his own soul, which makes
for some hellishly good action and stylish
fight sequences with an otherworldly flair.
Better buckle up for this high-speed film
ride.
When it comes to Cage's sci-fi surprises,
2009's "Knowing" is a must-see.
In the film, he portrays John Koestler, a
grieving widower and celebrated astrophysics
professor who gets his hands on a bizarre
list of dates and coordinates that relate
to major catastrophes throughout recent history.
"9/11/01?"
But he soon discovers that the numbers don't
only relate to past calamities – they predict
future ones.
He finds himself right in the thick of the
chaos, and begins to suspect that the numbers
point to some dark moments for mankind in
the near future.
As John scrambles to protect his child from
the voices that are creeping into his own
head and the impending disaster, Cage delivers
a searing performance as a parent who has
to grapple with the impossible before it's
too late.
"How am I supposed to stop the end of the
world?"
John Woo's 2002 war film "Windtalkers" centers
on the Navajo code talkers who helped lead
the troops to victory in World War II's Pacific
theater by using a code that was indecipherable
to enemy forces.
In the film, Cage delivers a riveting performance
as Sgt.
Joe Enders, who’s assigned to the crucial
undercover mission of protecting a code talker,
Private Ben Yahzee, from being captured at
all costs.
When he and his fellow Marines find themselves
in an ambush, Enders has to decide whether
to follow direct orders or forge his own path
forward through the skirmish.
As Enders, Cage brings both valor and vulnerability
to the role, and what results is a poignant
picture about a critical part of the Allied
success in the war.
Some of Cage's best roles are those that allow
him to show who he is, rather than spelling
out the nuances of the character through dialogue.
In 2013's "Joe," he plays something of an
antihero with a mysterious, checkered past.
Although Joe prefers to keep his own company,
he takes a shine to a young man who stumbles
onto his worksite looking for a job.
The boy, Gary, is hard-working but troubled,
and soon, Joe finds out why.
The kid’s father is an abusive alcoholic.
Though Joe is initially inclined to stay out
of it, as the details of Gary's home life
come into view, he has no choice but to act,
putting his own peace and security at risk.
"And if I find out something's happening to
that boy, I'm gonna whip whoever's ass had
something to do with it."
Put simply, Joe isn’t your average Joe,
nor your prototypical heroic figure, and Cage's
understated performance perfectly captures
the character in this thoughtful action drama.
In the 1993 neo-noir thriller “Red Rock
West,” Cage plays Michael Williams, a combat
veteran who stumbles into the wrong place
at the wrong time.
When he heads to the town of Red Rock, Wyoming,
in search of work, he gets way more than he
bargained for when he’s mistaken for a hitman.
But when the actual hitman – portrayed by
Dennis Hopper – arrives, the real chaos begins.
Soon, Michael finds himself in the middle
of a deadly domestic dispute, with a hitman
and a powerful, rage-filled sheriff on his
tail.
This stylish little thriller has a bit of
everything – high-speed chases, clever jailbreaks,
and some very surprising twists, and Cage
is as charismatic as ever in the role.
If you want to see a film that allows Cage
to channel every inch of his ability to become
unhinged on-screen, look no further than Werner
Herzog's jarring crime drama "Bad Lieutenant:
Port of Call New Orleans."
"Shoot him again."
"What for?"
The film features the actor as one of the
Big Easy's most corrupt cops, Terence McDonagh.
Terence might’ve started out his career
as a by-the-book police officer, but throughout
the shocking events of the film, we watch
him unwind into a spectacular disaster whose
errant energy sends shockwaves throughout
the city.
He also deals with his own deteriorating grasp
on reality.
As the consequences of his bad behaviors bubble
up and his grip on sanity continues to wane,
Terence chooses to lean into his warped views
of justice, leading to one breathlessly messy
action-adventure and a truly riveting screen
turn for Cage fans.
The "National Treasure" series is electric
from start to finish, and is a definite must-watch
for Nicolas Cage fans.
In the first film, released in 2004, Cage's
character, Benjamin Franklin Gates, decides
he must steal the Declaration of Independence
in order to protect it – and the treasure
map on the back of it.
Meanwhile, in the second pic from 2007, he
has to kidnap the actual president of the
United States in order to get his hands on
another map that leads to a fabled city of gold.
In both films, Cage imbues the character with
a true sense of honor, unstoppable charm,
and a commitment to protecting the most precious
pieces of the past — even if that means
being completely reckless along the way.
"Here's to the men who did what was considered
wrong, in order to do what they knew was right."
With centuries-old conspiracies and some larger-than-life
set pieces, the "National Treasure" series
is a wholesome double adventure for all ages.
The star-studded 2000 smash hit film "Gone
in 60 Seconds" has a whole lot of glorious
roadway action.
Cage stars in the film as Randall "Memphis"
Raines, a retired car thief who has to quickly
assemble a crew who can help him track down
and steal 50 specific luxury cars in the space
of just three days to save his brother's life.
Together, the group puts pedal to the metal
to organize a speedy series of heists to take
place simultaneously across the city of Long
Beach, California.
What results is a smashing series of highway
chases involving some of the snazziest cars
that have ever been seen on screen.
And Cage is, as always, at his best as a smooth-talking
criminal who knows exactly what he wants.
"I don't have one here, however I do have
one in the warehouse."
"Superb. What else do you have in the warehouse?"
Superhero movies may come in all shapes and
sizes, but 2010's "Kick-Ass" is still one of a kind.
"I didn't say anything to anyone, I swear."
"Good move, Ass Kick."
The film centers on a nerdy kid named Dave,
who decides to try a superheroic alter ego
on for size — because why not?
The thing Dave doesn't know, though, is that
he isn't the only person training to deliver
some homegrown justice.
Amid his roughshod crime-fighting adventures,
Kick-Ass eventually meets Hit-Girl and her
vengeance-seeking father, Big Daddy, played
by Cage.
As Big Daddy, Cage is a real riot, parading
around in a Batman-esque suit and coaching
his daughter on how to destroy armies of goons
all by herself.
The role is darkly comedic and shows off Cage's
sublime gift for blending action sequences
with quirky anecdotes and some very off-the-wall
character moments.
"But it's really no more painful than a punch
in the chest."
"I hate getting punched in the chest."
"You're gonna be fine, baby doll."
Cage is particularly gifted at playing characters
who have a lack of scruples and absolutely
no regrets, and that's certainly the defining
characteristic of his character in 2005's "Lord of War."
Cage stars in the pic as Yuri Orlov, a successful
gunrunner who delights in providing arms to
some of the world's most dangerous individuals.
"By the mid '80s, my weapons were represented
in eight of the world's top ten warzones."
Alongside his brother, Yuri becomes a major
player in the 1982 Lebanon War and catches
the attention of Interpol, and, well, let's
just say he finds himself in the middle of
some very dangerous conflicts.
As Yuri, Cage is a complete enigma, bringing
both humor and horror to a story that's truly
engaging and intelligent.
"Can you bring me the gun of Rambo?"
"Part one, two, or three?"
Ridley Scott’s 2003 black comedy “Matchstick
Men” features Cage at the absolute top of his game.
His character, Roy Waller, is at once a cavalier
con artist and a desperately unraveling individual
with a lonely home life.
His ability to smooth-talk unsuspecting marks
into handing over their hard-earned money
is impressively strong, but he’s also hanging
on by a thread when it comes to his own sanity
and sense of purpose.
"I know, but this is an emergency."
"Hey buddy, ever heard of a line?"
"Hey, have you ever been dragged down the
sidewalk and beaten until you pissed blood?"
Things take a major turn for Roy when he’s
introduced to the teen daughter he didn't
know he had, Angela, and decides to embrace
his dad status and teach her all he knows
about running a game.
"You're ready for this."
"I was born ready."
"Whew, glad I missed that day."
But as the stakes of his heists reach new
heights and his mental health continues to
waver, Roy has to worry about more than just
his own financial interests for the first
time in his life.
Things eventually culminate into a gloriously
chaotic climax with some dynamite twists that
keep you guessing right until the end.
1987's "Raising Arizona" was one of Nicolas
Cage's first major films, but it contains
one of his all-time greatest comedic-action
performances.
The movie, which helped bring the Coen brothers
into the mainstream, features the star as
"Hi" McDunnough, a former convict who marries
a police officer named Ed.
After they decide they want to have children
but are unable to bear or adopt any themselves,
Hi and Ed decide to kidnap one of the quintuplet
sons of a famous furniture magnate and raise
him as their own.
Though they initially try to raise him as
little "Junior" and pass him off as their
own biological child, things get completely
out of hand once the couple is reacquainted
with some of Hi's former pals from prison,
as well as other wildcard characters like
Hi's offensive foreman and a monstrous biker
from Hell.
From there, poor Junior becomes the unwitting
centerpiece of some blackly hilarious and
action-packed exchanges.
"Son, you got a panty on your head."
"Just drive fast, okay?"
It's not often that a movie with intense fighting
and a complicated game of cat and mouse can
also be a meaningful meditation on grief,
but that's exactly what "Pig" manages to pull off.
The film features Cage as Rob, a man who lives
completely off the grid in the forest alongside
his prized pig.
They spend their days hunting truffles, but
when his talented pig is stolen amid a violent
attack, he has to return to the city to face
his mysterious past in order to save her.
"I'm looking for a truffle pig."
"I don't, I don't understand."
Though the film is dripping with dread and
features some very satisfying moments of action,
it’s also refreshingly subversive and emotionally
engaging.
Anchoring it all is Cage's sensational and
critically revered leading performance in
the pic, which proves that even as accomplished
as he already is, he's still got many surprises
up his sleeve.
Nicolas Cage has always had some strong rock-and-roll
energy, and the 2018 horror flick “Mandy”
is a prime example of that.
The psychedelic film features the actor as
Red Miller, a reclusive logger who’s content
to spend his quiet life with his girlfriend,
Mandy.
Their peace is completely shattered, however,
when a terrifying hippie cult attacks the
couple in their home with the help of some
demonic bikers.
In addition to being a gonzo revenge story,
the film is a gory, scary sensory experience,
with Cage's deliciously berserk performance
bringing all the batty action home.
"Welcome to the Rock."
The cast of 1996's "The Rock" is a veritable
who's who of action movie all-stars from the era.
Cage stars as FBI Special Agent Dr. Stanley
Goodspeed, a lab geek who has to work alongside
a group of Navy SEALs and a highly classified
spy turned prisoner — played by Sean Connery
— to infiltrate the notorious Alcatraz prison
after it's taken over by a group of dangerous
former Marines.
Audiences are treated to a taut thrillride
packed with plenty of punches and, as is the
custom in any good Cage movie, a lot of iconic
moments.
For a film that manages to incorporate all
of the trappings of a traditional action film,
John Woo's "Face/Off" is still an incredibly
original thrill.
Sure, you may have seen planes crash into
hangars, high-speed boat chases, and mega
shootouts on-screen before, but chances are
good that you’ve never seen these events
unfold during a blood feud between two people
wearing each other's faces.
At least, not until you check out this 1997
classic.
"You know, I can, uh, eat a peach for hours."
The film features Cage and John Travolta playing
dual roles, with Cage starting off as the
ruthless criminal Castor Troy before his face
is surgically switched with John Travolta's
FBI Agent Sean Archer.
With their roles reversed and each man pretending
to be the other around their family members
and colleagues, the performances of Cage and
Travolta are exquisitely nuanced and off-kilter.
"Wow, we've got something in common."
They also both seem to be having the absolute
time of their lives in these roles, which
amplifies the rush factor as this memorable
action ride brings the duo together for an
epic – that's right – face-off.
There are many, many roles that seem to have
been specifically crafted for Nicolas Cage's
unique screen talents, but 1997's "Con Air"
truly hinges on his particular gifts.
Here, he stars as Cameron Poe, a decorated
combat veteran who’s sent to prison after
drunkenly killing a man who attacked his wife.
While incarcerated, he ends up on board a
prison transport plane with the country's
most hardened criminals, who scheme to take
over the plane and escape from custody.
For Cage fans, this film has a little bit
of everything that makes him such a Hollywood
legend.
The character is tough but vulnerable, serious
but also self-aware, and he has some unforgettable
one-liners that only he can deliver.
"I said, put the bunny back in the box."
Put simply, when it comes to Nic Cage's most
iconic action films, "Con Air" truly nails
the landing.
With all of these amazing performances under
his belt, it's no wonder Cage manages to corral
such intense fandemonium from the likes of
Javi in "The Unbearable Weight of Massive
Talent," a must-see theatrical experience
you should catch with friends in all its action-packed
glory this weekend.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.